bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france conseil
de défense donc olive et veyran
s'exprime sur france 2 ce soir
la semaine prochaine il y aura un autre
conseil de défense sanitaire le
gouvernement on voit qu'il est au
travail à l'offensive
il se donne cette image d'être au
travail on a surtout l'impression d'un
gouvernement perdu dans cette crise qui
perdure avec des conseils de défense sur
conseil de défense c'est toujours à peu
près le même scénario un conseil de
défense le matin tout ça est bien sûr
privé autour des vrais de macron qui
décide
entouré de quelques personnalités
choisies et puis un membre de l'exécutif
par le soir pour expliquer aux français
ce qui a été décidé en privé le matin
autour d'une table aujourd'hui c'est
olivier ferrand qui s'y colle parfois
c'est jean castex parfois c'est emmanuel
macron mais les voeux arrive entre les
deux conseils de défense celui de cette
semaine est celui de la semaine
prochaine donc ce soir c'est la
politesse alors via olivier ferrand qui
va sans doute annoncer est bien de faire
attention pour le jour de l'an pas de
nouvelles mesures puisque on attendra le
conseil de défense de la semaine
prochaine sans doute une campagne bien
sûr de vaccination qui commence très
doucement donc sans doute l'a expliqué
pourquoi qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est
ce qui est prévu dans les jours qui
viennent et toujours peut-être cette
question da re confinement locales cette
fois ci puisque certaines régions dont
le grand est ont du mal apparemment à
baisser les chiffres de contamination et
ça ne va pas aider avec de nombreux
touristes britanniques et autres qui
sont repartis de suisse dans la nuit
en disparaissant souhaitant porter ou
non du virus mais on ne sait pas avec ce
virus mutant qui qui visiblement est
plus agressif en termes de contamination
que le
l'ancien que 8,19 tel qu'il était lors
de la première vague
donc c'est à peu près toujours la même
chose on s'y est habitué
on va peut-être aussi demandé plus de
clarté plus de transparence sur cette
campagne de vaccination ait plus de
clarté sur cattan finalement le
gouvernement pour mettre sur la table un
plan clair et arrêté d'improviser de
semaine en semaine
donc pas suffisamment de clarté selon
vous du côté de du gouvernement dans le
cadre de sa stratégie et de lutte contre
le coc vie de dix neuf jusqu'ici est ce
que vous c'est pas un peu sévère tout de
même je crois pas que c'est sévère si on
regarde cette équipe qui est en charge
depuis le mois de mars tout est à la
fois à fonction contradictoires tout est
parfois mensonges et et tout et dire
tout et son contraire rappelez-vous
début mars et noël macro et son épouse
brigitte aller au théâtre et nous disait
que ce virus ne devait pas nous arrêter
de vivre
bon et bien les théâtres ne sont pas
prêts de rouvrir pas plus que les
cinémas il y a eu ensuite le fiasco des
masques c'est tout de même incroyable de
voir tous les responsables et porte
parole de la majorité qui se gaussait
sur les plateaux de télévision doc les
masques ne servait à rien que c'était
ridicule qu'enfin on n'en avait pas
besoin
jérôme salomon qui avait menti qui avait
voulu cacher son mensonge lorsqu'à un
rapport du sénat l'avait pointé du doigt
il avait lui-même choisi de ne pas
renouveler le stock stratégique lumière
jérôme salomon il n'a pas été
démissionné il n'a pas démissionné il a
toujours toute la confiance de ce
gouvernement et du président de la
république il est là donc qu'attendre de
cette équipe qui a à la fois raté le
premier confinement puisque nous voilà
reconfirmer une deuxième fois et peut
être une troisième fois localement ou
pas qui a raté les masques et les
commandes de masques y sont arrivés bien
en retard et beaucoup de soignants n'ont
souffert certains en sont morts
puisqu'il manquait de matériel et qui a
raté les tests la phase de test puisque
nous n'avons pas eu une phase de test
non plus à la hauteur de ce qui était
attendu et là nous voilà dans la phase
de vaccination avec la même équipe qui
est à deux puis récompensé pour sa
médiocrité
qu'attendre si ce n'est un fiasco de
plus je crois que on a vu les chiffres
de ce week end
moins d'une centaine de personnes
vaccinées dans les ehpad en france c'est
lui entre 10000 et 20000 selon les
sources qui ont été vaccinées en
allemagne on est reine
en france tout le monde nous regardons
mais qu'est ce qu'il se passait ce que
c'est un problème de logistique est ce
que c'est un problème de chaîne du froid
est ce que c'est tout simplement parce
que encore une fois on n'a rien préparé
alain fischer monsieur vaccin est
totalement inaudible invisible c'est le
monsieur invisible de cette campagne de
vaccination il a parlé une fois sur une
radio pour dire que tout allait bien
c'était normal de commencer doucement
oui il dit que c'est normal de commencer
doucement mais est ce qu'on a à votre
avis ce qu'on est suffisamment armé ce
qu'on a suffisamment de doses pour mener
cette campagne de vaccination dans les
meilleures conditions et l'élargir
surtout alors c'est là que ça va devenir
intéressant puisque nous avons décidé de
commenter massivement au niveau européen
à la fois pour la mise sur le marché de
ces vaccins celle autorités de santé
européennes qui décide la même autorité
de santé qui avait décidé de mettre leur
md et vire sur le marché un médicament
dangereux pour les malades du corps vide
mais tout ça grâce à la pression des
lobbys comme celui de gilead et bien
voilà que nous avons commandé les
vaccins au niveau européen et nous
allons voir si nous avons suffisamment
de doses tout simplement
aujourd'hui plusieurs candidats vaccins
arrivent sur le marché
seulement six heures et biotech le
vaccin arn semble être capable de
répondre à la demande
astrazeneca a pris beaucoup de retard
l'institut pasteur a pris beaucoup de
retard
visiblement l'europe ne veut pas
entendre parler de vax arbus ou venant
d'ailleurs donc c'est un riser qui fait
un jackpot avec ursula von der leyen qui
vient de déclarer que l'union européenne
allait commander 300 millions de doses
de plus de ce vaccin parce que voilà les
autres vaccins n'arrive pas or on nous
avons le docteur swami natale qui est
quand même la chef médical de l'om
est-ce l'organisation mondiale de la
santé qui nous dit que sur ce vaccin et
les autres vaccins d'ailleurs candidat
rien ne nous prouve aujourd'hui que ces
vaccins empêche d'attraper la maladie et
de la transmettre
et certains veulent parler de passeports
vaccinale pour passer d'un pays à
l'autre mais être vaccinés ne veut pas
dire que vous ne pouvez pas transmettre
la maladie aujourd'hui c'est l'om et
semaine qu'il ne dit donc au delà même
d'avoir
11 reste à savoir si ces stratégies
vaccinales va porter ses fruits et si
nous verrons bien
quelque chose se passait mais clairement
aujourd'hui voir qu'en france nous
prenons un tel retard alors que le
vaccin est censé être l'alpha et l'oméga
du déconfinement et de la reprise
économique
c'est inquiétant et politiquement ça
peut être un coup fatal pour emmanuel
macron même si certains sondages comme
d'habitude le donne à ces eaux
ça me paraît quand même assez cocasse
parce que là on commence à se poser
beaucoup de questions depuis mars
tout est mensonge manipulation pas
vraiment de transparence et ratages
alors est-ce que la vaccination sera pas
ratage de plus 2020 terre nous le dira
mais aujourd'hui l' oms reste très
prudente quant à la suite des opérations
en tout cas sur cette question d'y et
dur consignes mans locales dans
certaines régions le gouvernement refuse
pour l'instant de deux statues et
olivier ferrand s'exprime en ce moment
sur l'antenne de france 2 il affirme que
la date butoir du 7 janvier fixée par le
premier ministre en tout cas c'est une
date donc pour laquelle il sera
difficile de lever la totalité des des
contraintes c'est ce qu'il affirme et
apparemment n'envisage pas non plus
d'euros confirmant locaux comme le
demande la plupart à beaucoup d'élus ben
voilà on va continuer à être confiné on
va continuer à sacrifier les petits
commerces des le secteur de la culture
qui je pense maintenant on attend plus
de réouvrir les restaurateurs qui même
s'ils ont reçu des aides savent très
bien que ces aides vont toucher à leur
fin et qu'il faudra rembourser les
dettes
voilà où nous en sommes parce que
stratégie vaccinale mal organisé où sont
les 50 super congélateur une entreprise
française près de lyon un produit des
supers congélateur elle a dit notamment
récemment dans un article le
gouvernement français n'avait passé
aucune commande auprès d'elle pour des
super congélateur la chaîne du froid va
t elle être respectée aurons-nous
suffisamment de doses est déjà
aujourd'hui sur les doses on va vacciner
que les personnes les plus fragiles donc
dans les ehpad et et certains soignants
déjà là on a pas que les soignants et
puis un autre problème important
problème ou donner à voir les français
sont extrêmement sceptique par rapport à
ce nouveau vaccin
on est les champions du monde en fait
40 % seulement de la population qui
souhaitent se faire vacciner
c'est très très peu hélas comme il n'y a
pas vraiment d'exemple donné d'en haut
ni emmanuel macron ni les membres du
gouvernement ni personne finalement
essaye de faire une vraie campagne de
promotion de cette vaccination
peut-être de peur parce que l'opinion
publique n'y est pas prête et ce qui
s'était passé avec le h1n1
je crois qu'en france on a quand même le
souvenir de nombreux scandales
sanitaires que ce soit le sang contaminé
que ce soit le problème
donc voilà on va parler de cette
défiance d'ailleurs vis-à-vis du vaccin
ça concerne pas seulement les français
mais je le rappelle donc olivier ferrand
s'exprime sur france 2 actuellement il
annonce que ce n'est pas certain que la
totalité des contraintes soient levés au
7 janvier par ailleurs il se pourrait
qu'il y ait un couvre-feu à 18h
envisagée à partir du 2 janvier dans
certains départements merci à vous ou à
l'excès poulain